hey we're over here of Toshiba CES in
Las Vegas and if you remember before Tom
Cruise like crazy he was in this
actually pretty cool movie called
Minority Report where he was controlling
the inner computer interface with his
hands just purely with his hands and we
actually got something here that's
actually a concept product from Toshiba
where they're using a software interface
and a motion sensor an infrared motion
sensor to detect gestures to make
selections of photos right now thank you
pretty cool photos and videos that is
and I think eventually this could be
developed to reanimate gaming stuff like
that so even though this is a concept
product I don't see this taking too long
to go to market it's pretty basic stuff
it's pretty pretty existing technologies
like infrared sensors and just a
computer interface there's actually a
computer in this box next to this TV and
I just I think it's really cool I don't
I don't think it's gonna hit the
mainstream in any way I don't think
people were gonna be solving crimes with
this or anything but it's it's going to
be a niche product that'll be a pretty
cool thing to have at home if maybe some
video games and stuff